joining us now with reaction to our top
story and that story South Carolina
Senator Lindsey Graham so Kathleen
Cadillac and Bruce or before the first
FISA warrant was ever signed said steel
hates Trump Hillary paid for it and it's
unverified but they used it anyway and
then you heard what rod Rosenstein said
and then you just heard john solomon's
report help me out senator sounds to me
like a premeditated conspiracy to commit
fraud on the court to undo a first stop
and then undo a presidential election
that's how I interpret it well mchavez o
said without the dossier there would
have been no warrant issued against
Carter page so mccabe says under oath it
was outcome-determinative and everything
you said about the garbage nature of the
dossier I think it's true but this is
one we have mr. Horowitz looking into
this and I can't wait till he tells us
what he found
yeah all right so where do you go with
this because you're the one guy that can
bring them all in and I really do hope
senator that the people that did this
also were involved in rigging the
investigation into Hillary the evidence
is pretty overwhelming she violated the
Espionage Act and then she obstructed
justice for my little you know my little
TV studio and Martha little I know about
these things well I don't want to ask
Comey why did you tell the president in
January of 2017 here's the dossier we
don't I can't verify it but I want you
to know about it and he used the same
document and told the court that it's
reliable on four different occasions I
want to know will McCabe reaffirm again
that without the dossier there'd be no
warrant I want to find out did
Papadopoulos tell them up front that you
know if I was working with Russians I'd
be a crime I would never do that I want
to know a bunch of things I want to know
a lot okay so you're gonna get to bottom
of all of that let me ask you this
question so we got new leadership the
20/20 Democratic hopefuls all seem to be
reacting to and adopting the policies of
those squatters I guess they're called
now and I think I look at the new Green
Deal and I look at every Democrat saying
yeah medicare-for-all everything's
free no oil no gas no combustion engined
plains or cows and I said okay that's
the end of the United States as we know
it if that ever is implemented yeah well
so their policy choices would devastate
free enterprise it would make us we
could be the end of Israel as we know it
it would be devastating to the American
Way of life our prosperity in our future
compare that to what Trump's done name
one person in my lifetime has been a
better friend to Israel
we got the strongest economy in decades
and we got a military on par with what
Ronald Reagan did and we got a foreign
policy that makes sense I think a
compare and contrast campaign is gonna
lead to a very big Trump victory okay so
do you think in the time that Donald
Trump's been elected till now do you
think he's lost and he if or some of the
supporters they seem pretty passionate
tonight North Carolina and do you think
maybe the best employment situation
since 1969 and record low unemployment
for all these varied demographic groups
when you break it down that some
traditionally vote Democratic do you
think he's got a shot at those voters
now here's what I think I think he's
United the Republican Party every corner
of the party believes that President
Trump is doing a good job with a few
outliers if you're a strong national
security guy he's like Reagan if you
believe in cutting taxes as a
conservative Republican he did it if you
believe in conservative judges nobody's
done better so from a Republican point
of view you don't have a whole lot to
complain about compare that to our
friends on the other side who are
cracking up Lindsey Graham on Hannity I
can see you really want to revise and
extend your remarks Thank You senator